When I was in senior year university,
this was around 2004,
I was in one of those classes
where the teacher would read
the slides word-for-word
as part of a three-hour lecture.
Oh.
Oh, you all know what I'm talking about?
(Laughter)
I ended up doing alright in the class
by catering to my own learning style.
After a little bit of experimentation,
I found that playing a video game
during this lecture,
a game like Tetris,
or in this particular case,
"Zelda: The Minish Cap,"
helped me pay attention
because the primary way
I engage with information is by listening.
And this meant
that the teacher's voice
with matching text
were a distraction for me.
Anyway, I was at the back listening
and participating, mind you.
But one day, this teacher
decided to call me out.
He stopped the class and said, "Excuse me.
Are you playing video games in my class?"
And then I said,
"I am, sir, but this is
the way that I learn."
And then he said,
"There's no way
that you're learning anything."
And then I said,
"Sir, I'm not interrupting.
I am learning,
and I’m even participating.”
And then he said, "No, I don't want you
playing video games in my class."
And then I said, "Sir ..."
(Laughter)
And then I said, "Sir, I'm going to place
this Game Boy Advance on the table,
repeat your last two
sentences word-for-word,
and then I’m going to pick up
this Game Boy Advance and keep playing.”
And then he said,
"I don't think you can do that."
And then the class went, “Oooooh.”
(Laughter)
You can picture that, alright, cool.
So I placed my Game Boy
Advance on the table,
I looked him right in his eye,
repeated his last two sentences,
word-for-word,
and then I picked up my Game Boy
Advance and kept playing.
(Laughter)
And then you know what he said?
"Alright, carry on."
(Laughter)
So since that day,
I’ve become a professor myself ...
of video game design.
And I'm convinced
that there's absolutely something
that video games can teach
the world of academia.
Like, how they can cater
to human learning,
how they can enhance online instruction
and how they can provide clear objectives.
Let me explain.
Humans can take in information
in three core ways:
audio, text and video.
Now, as I demonstrated earlier,
I'm an oral learner,
which means I prefer
to take in information via sound.
And some studies show that when two
or more of these channels are used,
learning gains are higher.
But, there's a catch.
Now, I was struggling to pay
attention in this class
because of something
called cognitive overload,
which can happen when audio,
text and video
aren't different enough
when used together.
So when the audio of my teacher matched
the excessive text on his slides,
my brain was overloaded.
Teachers who use technology
in the classroom
need to ensure that each
channel is complementary,
otherwise, students are going to have
difficulty transferring information
from working memory to long-term memory.
Now, I fixed the problem for myself
by essentially using the teacher's voice
as the soundtrack
for the game I was playing.
And this brings me to my first point.
Video games, by design,
are a complex blend of audio, text,
video and interactivity
that can intensify focus.
That was the point of my PhD.
(Laughter)
And because of their enjoyment factor,
these components of video games
can help with something
our students desperately
need in the classroom:
motivation.
Now, at their best,
video games can immerse us,
focus our attention
and provide clear objectives
with demonstrated output.
You know how well you're doing
every step of the way.
And video games can teach
multiple things simultaneously.
Like ...
There's this class I teach,
game design,
where I like to use
a video game called “Virginia.”
Now, in “Virginia,”
you play as Anne Tarver,
a newly-hired FBI agent
who is tasked with internally
investigating someone
who just happens to be the only
other female agent in the precinct.
And this game is based on a true story.
Now, on the surface, I’m using “Virginia”
to teach game design.
But I'm also using
the mechanics of video games
to trick students into exploring
complex concepts
like history, sexism, racism,
corporate culture and tokenism
while we play this game together.
To me, effective instruction
merges theory and practice.
Each week in this class,
I like to pick a unique video game
that matches the game theory
and sprinkles in
a couple of life takeaways.
We play the game together
and talk about it,
and then the students have to go
and make video games themselves.
And this all happens -- wait for it --
online.
(Laughter)
And guess what?
COVID forced everyone
to join me teaching online,
and most schools struggled.
But there are many examples
of effective online instruction
in unlikely places like YouTube streams,
Netflix programming,
and, believe it or not, Amazon's Twitch.
Now, as you probably know,
Twitch is an online streaming platform
where people can watch
other people play video games.
But it can also be used to learn
how to paint with Ergo Josh.
Learn how to play piano with Juanorpiano.
Learn how to code with RothioTome
and even how to cook meals
with yarumichan.
Uh-huh, yeah, real.
(Laughter)
And Twitch had an average of 2.78 million
concurrent viewers in 2021.
Now, that's a lot of motivated learners
if you actually think about it.
One of my favorite classes to teach online
is a class called Esports Broadcasting,
where I'm essentially
just using video games
to teach students how to professionally
present themselves online
using a free piece of software called
Open Broadcaster Software, or OBS.
Here, I teach them how to connect
any available camera to the software.
Add white balance
(Laughter)
and color correction
to help that image pop,
(Laughter)
use on-screen text
to complement the video,
(Laughter)
and compress any available microphone
to make it sound and look
exactly like what they're accustomed
to consuming online.
And the same processes
that hooked viewers on Twitch
are the same processes schools should use
to learn how to engage students
online and globally.
That should be one
of their objectives, shouldn't it?
(Laughter)
Hold on.
What are the objectives
of a post-secondary education anyway?
And what could education overall
learn from video games,
which clearly say:
start here,
do these things
and then obtain these things.
Now, if the goal
of a post-secondary education
includes students getting a job
in the same thing they went to school for,
guess what?
Schools are failing.
More than half of graduates
do not get jobs in their field of study.
That would be like enrolling
in chef training
and then graduating
to start a job in data analytics.
Why not just enroll in data analytics?
You could.
Grow with Google has an online program
promising you a job in data analytics
starting at 74,000 dollars a year,
and that program is free to start.
Epic Games offers a pathway
to become a developer
with its Unreal Engine
for interactive 3D development,
a field that they say
has gone up 601 percent
and is paying people 57 percent more
than the average salary.
For clarity, their Unreal Engine
is the same tool used to build Fortnite
and the same tool used to build
some of the backgrounds
behind "The Mandalorian."
At no cost to use.
Are y'all hearing all these near-free,
no-fee examples I'm giving you?
(Laughter)
University in particular is mad expensive.
The cost of university has gone up
1,200 percent since 1980.
To me ...
To me, there's not a single job,
trade or discipline
that doesn't in some way connect
to the video games industry.
There are dentists
like Dr. August de Oliveira,
who are using augmented reality
to see the roots of your teeth
while working on your teeth.
Psychologists are using virtual reality
to help you overcome a fear of spiders,
and broadcast technicians responsible
for filming a dragon
flying over a live stadium full of people
as part of a League of Legends
esports broadcast.
Video game technologies
are embedded in all of these.
And that must mean that the video games
industry is not just made of players
but made of you.
Now, I'm not suggesting that video games
replace classroom instruction --
Settle down, internet.
(Laughter)
I'm advocating for
the components of video games,
especially the engaging ones,
to be ported into classroom instruction
because the audience, the students,
clearly understand the medium.
There are roughly three billion
video game players worldwide.
Video games contain the blueprint
for engaging education
because of the way that they cater
to human learning,
a complex story interwoven
with learning content
and a bit of artificial intelligence
for difficulty and balance.
Online instruction can be enhanced
if schools turn to top
streaming platforms and streamers
to learn how to effectively
engage students online.
And the objectives for education overall
need to be as specific as a video game
so that those who are enrolled
have a clear line of sight
to where they're headed.
If we can start showing students
how their passion for playing
connects to their futures,
we will have done our jobs.
The next generation of teachers
are those who can connect
the path of study
to profession via passion.
Oh, and one last thing
about the playing of video games.
There's a 2022 study suggesting
that the playing of video games
is associated with heightened cognition,
faster reaction times,
improved working memory
and modifying the cortical networks
associated with the process of playing.
And that ...
is what I should have said
to that teacher.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)